One third of my country,
Pakistan, is under water.
An exceptional monsoon
coupled with flash flooding
due to the accelerated melting
of the Himalayan glaciers
has led to devastating flooding.
Floods so destructive, so all-consuming,
that the adjective most frequently used
to describe them is “biblical.”
The area of land that is underwater
is larger than Britain.
Over 33 million people are affected,
stripped of homes and livelihoods.
Hundreds have been killed,
and those that survived
are now dying of malaria,
dengue fever, diarrhea.
The crops that we planted
have been washed away,
and our fields will be waterlogged
for many months to come,
imperiling the critical
wheat-planting season.
Pakistan is in shock,
and all it can look ahead to
is food insecurity, famine,
climate migration and conflict.
Pakistan needs tens of billions
in emergency relief funds,
and it needs them right now.
But I'm not here to talk
about today's crisis.
I'm here to talk about the way forward.
As the scale of devastation
becomes apparent,
the sense of climate
injustice is mounting.
Pakistan emits less than one percent
of global greenhouse gases,
and yet it is consistently
among the countries
most vulnerable to disasters
caused by climate change.
That vulnerability
has been horrifyingly laid bare
over the last few months.
Calls are growing for the global North
to compensate the global South
for the fact that high-emitting activities
in developed economies
are leading to catastrophic
climate change-linked events
in less developed countries.
Since the Industrial Revolution,
today's wealthy nations
have benefited economically
from high-emitting activities.
The G20 are still responsible
for 80 percent of global
greenhouse gas emissions.
The logic is simple:
industrialized nations that have profited
from fossil-fuel-driven development
should be the ones to pay the bill
when climate disasters strike
poor countries such as mine.
This idea is not new,
nor is it particularly controversial.
In 2009,
developed countries promised
to mobilize billions in climate finance
to support emerging economies.
That funding has not materialized.
And so the demands for reparations have.
But let's be clear.
Developing countries
are not asking for charity.
Having polluted only marginally,
they are climate creditors,
and that credit is now due.
As I said, the logic is simple.
But the politics are complicated.
Developing countries have not
consistently demanded reparations
for climate change-linked
loss and damage.
Many countries in the Global South,
led by India and China,
subscribe to the “catch up” argument:
the notion that developing countries
should now be allowed their share
of pollutants and greenhouse gases
in order to build infrastructure
and spur economic growth.
This reasoning envisions
the West curtailing emissions
and bearing the financial cost
of the economic slowdown,
while developing countries
continue to emit,
build and grow.
It's a way of saying,
"Hey, it's our turn."
This "catch up" argument is compelling,
but it does not speak
the language of reparations.
Climate justice is based on the notion
of not being punished
for someone else's bad behavior.
It does not sanction more bad behavior.
You cannot both demand reparations
and the right to emit.
But many developing countries
have yet to engage in climate diplomacy,
a process of reconciling the demand
for reparations with existing security
and foreign policies.
And so you'll see cases
where some government departments
are demanding climate justice,
while others are seeking foreign funding
for coal and gas projects
or pursuing defense deals
with high-emitting nations.
It is difficult to have it both ways.
And that's why demanding reparations
also means bringing forward
a clean, green vision --
one which includes leapfrogging
the high emitting stage
of economic development
into a more sustainable future.
For countries like mine,
that means no more
poorly planned expressways
or elite real estate developments
dotted with swimming pools
or golf courses in drought-hit areas.
Because sadly, it is true
that the scale of devastation in Pakistan,
and in climate calamities elsewhere,
is not just the result of climate change
but also a consequence of poor governance,
of inadequate planning,
the lack of infrastructure, corruption
and the lack of accountability.
This is something the Global South
must acknowledge.
But this is absolutely not
to place the onus back
on climate vulnerable
developing countries.
No.
Instead, it is to say
that the time has come
for the global North and South to agree
[on] the terms of a just transition.
Are we ready for a new social contract
within countries and between countries?
One way forward
is to adopt a more expansive
definition of reparations.
This should take the form of funding
for emergency relief, loss and damage,
but it should also include
technical assistance,
adaptation planning
and the skills development needed
to tackle the climate challenge.
Developed countries
should provide funding,
but they should also provide access
to the green technologies
that can help countries
such as Pakistan catch up,
but without the high emissions.
Pakistan is drowning,
and its people are desperate.
Their present is your future.
We need a new era of climate diplomacy,
and we need a new recognition
that we are in this together.
We can adapt, mitigate, build resilience,
but only if we do it together.
The logic of climate justice is simple.
Let's make the politics simpler to.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)
Bruno Giussani: Huma, thank you.
So when introduced you, I said
that the floods have not received
enough attention in the global media.
But how are the Pakistani media
talking and reporting about them?
Huma Yusuf: Thank you for that question.
You know, we’re just a month into
the declaration of a national emergency,
and the floods are already slipping out
of the news headlines in Pakistan.
I think we're really
suffering from the fact
that the 24-hour news cycle
does not know how to tell this story,
a story so big,
a story that requires you
to connect the dots
to every other story you will ever tell,
whether we're talking about food,
the economy, insecurity,
domestic militancy.
There is no story that can be told
without also telling this story.
But unfortunately, I don’t think
we have that media literacy,
and the floods are already receding
out of our own headlines.
So what can we expect
from the international press?
BG: Well, is aid already coming, at least?
HY: Aid is coming, but not enough
and not fast enough.
And, you know, Pakistan has said
that they need about 30 billion dollars
to help with the rehabilitation
and reconstruction phase.
And we're at a stage where, for example,
I think the UN tomorrow
launches a new appeal
that's for 600 million dollars.
So I don’t think that there
will ever be enough aid.
We do need some
of these reparations.
We need a better plan
for how we're going to fund
these kinds of climate disasters.
But unfortunately, even before
the money has started flowing,
those questions have started.
You know, where's the money
that's already come through gone?
Who is tracking it?
What is it being spent on?
And I fear that those kinds
of questions deter more funding,
when actually it's the absolute
need of the hour.
BG: Now, I want just to put an image
in the mind of people here.
One of our conversations,
you told me a story
about people in flooded areas
going around in small boats
and hitting structures under water.
Tell us about that.
HY: Yes, you saw the pictures
that I started with.
And I’ve been seeing those,
and I haven’t visited myself
the most badly affected areas.
And it was only when I received a video
from a friend of mine
who was out there reporting in the field,
which showed her on a boat going through
what I thought was a lake,
and then they start
bumping up against things --
and you realize that it’s the top
of electricity pylons,
and it's the top of school buildings
and it's the top of petrol stations
with the little, you know,
advertising symbol --
that I really understood
that my country is submerged.
It is truly underwater.
And I don't know
how you come back from that.
BG: Thank you for sharing this story
and thank you for your talk.
HY: Thank you for having me.
(Applause)